he's one of the stars of in the heights
which is in theaters near you and also
streaming exclusively on
hbo max enjoyed his work for many a moon
nypd blue la la just to name two
uh one of the stars again of in the
heights jimmy smits here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
good morning rich back at you with the
with the fan love
i've been listening to you for years and
years man
i really appreciate that so you're born
in brooklyn i'm born in brooklyn i'm
from staten island you know
uh you're now in the heights i i kind of
feel like i know you
in a way you know i kind of feel like i
know here
new york yes sir so sir
are you are you a a fan of any
particular sports team in new york
yankee matt
uh jet giant i'm you know them
them bombs that left brooklyn uh mm-hmm
i'm so happy that brooklyn has a
basketball team now
and that they're kicking that they're
doing so great
that's uh i'm i'm ecstatic yeah and i
follow the yankees i'm you know i'm
saying
i'm with my young kid okay very good uh
did you have a representation
do you ever favorite player growing up
at all jimmy that you uh remember
watching when you were growing up in new
york city
and just just checking it out while you
were going about your business
at all i remember my dad used to get
these tickets to go
to uh to go to yankee stadium and we met
joe pepitone a couple
why it was more than once oh see we'll
go back
oh yeah joe pepitone is a great name of
a gra
of a terrific yankee from back in the
day jimmy
i haven't heard that name in a while i
love that i was like uh that was that's
that's mickey mantle roger maris uh that
whole contender
of course no doubt about that and again
now i i i can't get enough of
uh in the heights jimmy and um you know
i i
i was watching it with my kids because
they're big hamilton fans
and i had it okay i had to explain to
them i'm like well if this sounds like
hamilton it's really hamilton sounds
like in the heights that in the heights
was before
lin-manuel uh came up with hamilton wha
what in the world is it like to work
with lin-manuel
miranda uh and see his talents on
display
or be uh having such an important part
of his
pop culture uh landscape placed in your
hands with the rest of the cast of in
the heights
jimmy yeah rich you said it right there
changing the landscape i remember seeing
uh an off-broadway uh iteration
of of in the heights and i had a friend
that was working at the drama bookstore
that told me about these kids
that's hid lin-manuel and his wesleyan
crew that were doing a workshop
of it downstairs in the drama bookstore
but
my wife and i saw the off-broadway
version and was like this is the new
wave they got it going they got it going
on here
listen to them it's so positive and then
to
you know see all the success that uh the
show had
in terms of changing the landscape of
what a broadway musical could look like
and how it was slaughtered
up i've been a huge supporter and then i
i saw lynn
a couple of years afterwards i was doing
the show on broadway myself and he had
just
taken a vacation from the show and was
telling me at the drama bookstore we
were both at john buster he said yeah i
was
reading this book about hamilton the guy
on the 10
bill yeah yeah he was he's an immigrant
man he's just like
we totally relate to the start and he
trotted away and the next thing i know
he was spitting rhymes at
the white house for obama
yeah he's uh there's a
there's a good soul there uh there's uh
a guy who you know he's got
he's got this love of broadway and and
positive messages and that that's what's
there in the film and
with the john two added on our director
and
in terms of the film some of these
visual homages that we have to the
golden age of cinema
it's just it makes me really really
happy with these universal themes that i
think
you know your kids probably picked up on
it's just joy happening and people wanna
people are ready for this you know the
universe aligned for us in a lot of ways
rich
in terms of the pandemic and
people having all this time being locked
up and
thinking about not only medical stuff
but social issues i think
you know it's people are right
for being around
other people audiences and acceptance of
joy and
what a summer musical can do you know
music
you remember you remember a song in the
summer time
sticks with you for life you can hear
that music and it just goes right back
to
that time so all those things are great
for the film i think
and a great cast a really talented young
cast
and and you're terrific in it too you
carry a couple tunes jimmy
uh i'm not gonna lie i mean that was it
was great it was great to hear i mean
you know you you you you're being um a
dad
and having some intense dramatic scenes
i'm used to that you know and i know
that you've you've been on broadway for
a very long time
i i i loved it i i got
i got to ch i got to check off my little
uh artistic bucket list
not just it's not just doing a little
musical here and there in summer stock
you know right
lynne manuel miranda in in the heights
and again you play
a dad whose daughter um is the
uh light of the community because she
makes it to stanford
and now she's has second thoughts about
it because she doesn't feel
welcome in the community there because
she's from washington heights
and her experience is growing up there
and her comfort level of growing up
there
makes her feel like a fish out of water
in stanford and it's just a beautiful
scene
uh you and you you and the actress who
plays your daughter
um and uh leslie grace fine
fine remarkable she's known she's known
as a singer but
this young lady she totally opened up
her heart and
you know gave 110
to the to the acting part of this as
well and some of the moments that she
has not only
in our scenes but with her her scene
partner corey hawkins
just beautiful beautiful beautiful
touching moment no doubt and you shot
much of this in washington heights
itself the community
uh of which this is based right did you
shoot it pretty pretty much
pretty much all of it rich yeah and that
that was in and of itself was
a joy i mean we weren't doing movie
catering for lunch we were going to the
you know community restaurants there and
you know lin-manuel miranda and kiara
alegria who this is the screenwriter and
wrote the broadway play they both are
from that neighborhood they lived there
you know and the neighborhood
is aware of them and their positiveness
about
what the the show represented when it
was on broadway so they knew we were
there and they buoyed us so many ways i
think
in terms of being positive and uh you
know uh
like i said it's just beautiful
everybody should go check it out either
in a theater
if you are uh so inclined or streaming
it exclusively on hbo max it's called in
the heights
uh based on the hit broadway musical
jimmy smith's here
on the rich eisen show i do want to hit
your career a little bit prior to this
film
jimmy because like i said i'm a big fan
but i i kind of want to hit the wayback
machine with you if you don't mind
the real wayback machine is it true that
you lasted you're talking about joe
pepito we might as well
why not if we're talking joe pepitone we
might we might as well talk about your
five-minute long stint on miami vice
is it true you were the you were the
first uh and uh partner of sonny
crockett's
on that show and you lasted five minutes
on miami
don't make it don't make it sound like i
got fired no no
that's the rule part of the job right
going in right that was
that is that is that true that that that
that was your one of your first
television roles
jimmy it was one of the first nighttime
thing
gigs that i did okay uh-huh what was
that like back in the day
to be involved it was it was so exciting
to be
well that was a pilot episode right so
to be you know i was doing off-broadway
theater working at the new york
shakespeare festival a lot
and uh and to be in miami and with this
these group of people who kind of had a
feeling
that they were doing something cutting
edge in terms of television
uh was really was really very exciting
and
uh yeah i remember don johnson
he and i were in a we're in a wardrobe
fitting together he took his
beautiful linen uh
jacket and kind of like balled it up and
put it in the corner says and he needs
to be rumpled he needs to be rumbling
why you that's why you resizing were
wearing uh
rumpled linen jackets after that
probably with your arms with the arms up
i just don't know if i really had the
ability to pull that off
to be honest with you jimmy back in the
day you know
uh i am also a big fan of you know with
all of these films
uh that that were born at the time and
also
uh came out of it like buddy buddy cop
movies in a way
running scared is a film that does not
get i don't think the do that it
deserves we had billy crystal on this
show the other day we've already
established
your broadway roots it must have been
quite something for you to be in that
film at an early part of your career and
gregory hines
was a co-star for you that had to be
something
for you jimmy i would imagine i had i
had so much fun working with those guys
in chicago in the middle of from
november through february we were there
when ooh shooting late nights
but it was it was a blast greg both
gregory and bill were
were so so nice to me right have you
have you watched
that at any time recently did you maybe
you know flipping the channels during
the during the uh
pandemic at all and coming across i
don't i don't really like to watch a lot
of
i saw i saw a clip of it recently
because we had some function that we had
to do in the
part of the clip package was one of the
scenes
from uh from from the film so uh
yeah there was some there was some stuff
there i bet i bet and then
uh one other uh aspect i want to hit you
on and that's a large part of your
career
my guys here will attest i'm not i swear
to you i'm not one of those los angeles
name droppers but
having moved out here to la one of the
most
cherished moments i've had is my wife
and i
became friendly with stephen bochko uh
and his wife dana
and um i i was a he stephen asked me for
his memoir to interview him to get the
stories out of his
mind right um as he was just finally
recovered from being sick for the first
time
what was it like to have your career
uh placed in the hands of somebody as
genius as him with l.a law
and nypd blue
jimmy richie you know we probably
wouldn't be talking right now if it
wasn't for
for that that
game changer in terms of uh what
televisions he uh
he changed my life um and really
you know permission to aspire he he did
that for so many people
um and and changed the way people
you know watched network television i
mean if
if somebody were trying to pitch nypd
blue now to the network tv i don't i
don't even know who would
it would get on but he's consistently
was just a a great person a wonderful
storyteller you know you know how
how funny he was and uh irreverent in so
many ways is willing to go up against
the network to push the envelope to make
to make television better
um and just told beautiful stories
beautiful story what is your favorite
moment of
of uh either one of those shows
la la you got a great moment for that
for me
like a good story la la for me was just
was
great because the ensemble was really
tight we all came from
well most of the cast came from came
from new york and had theater
backgrounds
what was funny was when we would get
together for these conference room
scenes that were part of the show when
we would discuss
what would be the cases of the week and
again theater backgrounds a lot of the
work
talking about the work and the scenes
and stuff and as the show became a
little more successful the conversation
started talking about house additions
and sure no
that that happens right and and then
just just a great cat
just a great cat and dennis franz uh was
he
he wasn't like sip wits at all right in
real life like that that's just how
great of an actor
he was that the two of you would be on
screen together for all those years
and it just felt so right with you and
him
and working together iconic and iconic
television role of uh
andy sipowicz that that dennis inhabited
for
a dozen years there and i you know i
just i feel so blessed to to be
partnered with him
the time that i was there and uh and the
situation the way that
you know the way it went down uh it like
the show
actually came back to me after after a
while
um and so and i got to do it and
and the partnership was just just just
just great we shoot in la the the
interior scenes but when we would come
to new york
the the new yorkers were just like
[Music]
hey
i bet and i'll just take one stab though
and say the biggest uh
points you might have ever earned with
your kids though is
being in star wars films would would i
would i would i peg that correctly or
or no that yeah that was that was up
there i didn't get it i didn't get a
lightsaber but uh they had a speeder so
they were hey they didn't give you life
hey look jimmy uh like i said i've been
a fan of yours for for quite some time
uh the fact that i was able to share in
the heights with my children
they love the music they love absolutely
everything about it
um and i can't wait for everybody to
share it with their kids or or whomever
uh it's a beautiful movie it's fun and
it was terrific and you're great in it
so thanks for the time i really
appreciate it oh richie thank you thank
you so much richie
thanks thanks for bringing up stephen
you you you did a
you did a great thing for my memory
banks no no i he's
you know my gratitude certainly when you
were talking about you know even
uh you know with miami vice saying that
they were
doing something with television that
that wasn't done before
i mean the idea of let's just not end an
episode with neatly tying up every
storyline let's have an entire
season-long arc or
multiple season-long story line arcs
previously on
i mean that we're all taking for granted
now that came out of his head
it's unbelievable absolutely absolutely
thanks again big bet you bet thanks for
the call that's jimmy smits everybody
check him out in the heights
in theaters nationwide now and streaming
exclusively on hbo max
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here